this world is not yet ready for all that
you will do
your time will come diana
and everything will be different
citizens of the
world i'm here to change your life
anything you want
[Music]
anything you dream of you can have it
no like you saw a ghost
diana lucky you
it's like not one day has passed
get used to it
i remember being one for rules
the answer is always more
the way i fly they will never find us i
forgot to tell you what radar will they
will they shoot at us
[Music]
barbara what did you do
you know i'm not so keen on this one i
figure uh you are but
you know what i'm ready to go
i think we can do better parachute pants
yeah um does everybody parachute now
welcome back everyone it's charlie happy
dc fandom you made it we have a bunch of
trailer footage to break down this will
be my wonder woman 1984 trailer we have
full blown comic book form cheetah
thankfully we do not have a cat's
situation on our hands so there's a
bunch of easter eggs we'll break it down
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos there's
going to be a bunch more trailers
tonight including the batman and the
justice league snyder cut trailer so
we'll just start at the beginning and go
through the trailer shot by shot most of
this is new footage which is great they
start with the scene of the flashback to
the olympics on themyscira when she was
a little girl there's sort of this
parable that they tell the story is all
about greed and excess because this is
the 80s that we're in during present day
like later in the trailer maxwell lord
couldn't say it better when he says to
cheetah all i know is more more more
i've never been one for rules that's
sort of a theme of the movie hippolyta
gives her a similar lesson in the
flashbacks when she's a little girl
competing in these olympics like the
quick and easy way is the way to the
dark side to make a star wars reference
but then you get the hippolyta voiceover
saying the world is not yet ready for
all you can do that's obviously a clever
wink at all the abilities that she has
all of her special powers i know
everybody's asking can she fly because
it seems like she flies a couple
different times during this trailer and
in the poster that they just revealed
yesterday she's also flying in the
golden armor because it has a set of
wings on it like while the voiceover is
happening she's running through the
olympics but they intercut her in
present day lassoing the lightning bolts
which is obviously totally crazy then
you see her running off of a building in
the gold armor before the wings have
unfurled so clearly she's going to fly
in that gold armor but maxwell lord is
then using the president's address
system to broadcast his message all over
the world it's hard to say exactly when
this is happening during the movie but
it's probably happening sometime near
when this white house fight between
cheetah and wonder woman is happening
because maxwell lord is there too you
just don't see him in this footage it's
just that she's there to protect him so
that he can give this message using the
president's broadcast system i love
while he's doing that too you go all
over the world you see all this 80s
technology all these old-timey computers
it's just great i love all the nostalgia
in this then he tells everyone around
the world you can have everything you
always wanted and they cut to the steve
trevor scene as she sees him for the
first time because steve trevor is what
wonder woman wants so he comes back to
life literally then because cheetah is
sort of a parallel for wonder woman's
arc during the movie you get her voice
over she says i don't want to be like
everyone else i want to be an apex
predator so all these cheetah scenes are
meant to be a dark mirror of all the
wonder woman scenes during the trailer
this is cena barbara minerva listening
to him this is i think from a different
part of the movie though but she's
inside the smithsonian where she works
she has that voice over talking to
wonder woman after she starts to get
wonder woman's powers and becomes more
powerful but she's not full comic book
cheetah form yet she still looks like a
human she tells wonder woman that she's
always had everything and people like
barbara minerva have never had anything
and that's going to change now so she's
basically in the process of taking her
powers over the course of the film
evolving slowly through the film into
the full comic book cheetah form while
this is happening you see wonder woman
walk into the smithsonian offices where
she works with cheetah but this is
obviously while cheetah is still barbara
minerva you get a bunch more of that
white house fight with her with the
lasso of true trying to take down those
guards this might be because maxwell
lord wishes himself to become the
president the wishing stone that they
use that special black rock that you saw
in the last trailer that's called the
dream stone that's basically what
enables everyone to get what it is that
they want with this big evil genie twist
it's kind of like a monkey's paw
situation you wish for something you get
it but you have to give up something of
yourself in return that's why wonder
woman is losing her powers because she
wants steve trevor she gets him but then
in order to get him she has to give the
rock her powers and the rock gives her
powers to cheetah the thing that cheetah
winds up giving up to get those powers
is her humanity literally and
metaphorically like when you see her
fighting wonder woman i love that she's
wearing those crazy leopard print
clothes just foreshadowing the full
transformation into cheetah you see
wonder woman trying to use her signature
gauntlet move to stop cheetah and she
just jumps right through it that's just
because by this point in the film she's
gotten so weak that it doesn't work
quite as well and she just gotten so
much more powerful that she can just
jump right through it then you see more
of that footage of the foreign situation
that wonder woman is trying to stop this
big war that's breaking out but she's
gotten weaker so she's having more
trouble stopping it while you have the
parallel of cheetah just starting to get
her powers getting stronger and faster
like she takes off into a run out of
that hotel like oh my god it's basically
the power montage that you get in a lot
of superhero films like in man of steel
when superman is first learning about
his abilities and trying to learn how to
fly but because it's cheetah it's a
little bit darker like she takes down
this mugger and just feels so powerful
oh this is so amazing i'm gonna be so
awesome now then you have maxwell lord
going full darth sidious to cheetah
telling her more more more who cares
about rules this is probably when
cheetah makes her second wish to become
the full apex predator and that's when
she turns into full comic book cheetah
form then you have wonder woman and
steve trevor trying to chase them down
in their plane stealing this jet but
steve trevor has this big joke about
being an amazing pilot they'll never
find us and then wonder woman's like
yeah i gotta tell you about that they
get some modern technology called radar
there's no way you can escape that the
footage of maxwell lord with the wind
blowing around him while he's using that
presidential address system is just the
magic of the dream stone working its
power then you have wonder woman versus
cheetah in her gold armor and full
cheetah form so this structure seems
like it's this big giant broadcast tower
in this foreign country that they're all
flying to but by this time it seems like
wonder woman has gotten most of her
power back after she sends steve trevor
back to death like she has to wish him
away in order to reverse her wish and
get her powers back and it's the same
for everybody all over the world like
chaos breaks out because everyone around
the world is making a wish wanting
things as maxwell lord tells them to do
because he's manipulating them that's
when you see all this chaos erupt in the
streets just because just crazy stuff
starts to happen to people the cheetah
fight seems pretty solid but i believe
she's supposed to end this movie still
being cheetah i don't think they're
completely ending that like they were
supposed to introduce her in the first
film and make her this really huge
villain so i think they have plans for
cheetah way down the road that she could
always come back in a future movie then
they have that other joke tag scene like
the trash one from the last trailer
where steve trevor comes out in
parachute pants does everybody parachute
now what's going on as funny as this is
doesn't this remind you of some of the
costumes from superman 4 the quest for
peace big surprise too patty jenkins
actually revealed that she wanted to
introduce cheetah during the first
wonder woman movie it would have
happened at the end of the film in
present day when she was at the louvre
just looking at the watch that steve
trevor gave her in the picture from
world war one we do know they're gonna
make wonder woman three and it's gonna
be set during present day but they
haven't said who the main villain of
that's going to be i know a lot of
people have been asking for cersei so
let me know in the comments who do you
want the villain of wonder woman 3 to be
if it's going to be said in present day
and which other justice league
characters do you want to see cross over
into that movie because that's part of
the reason why you do films set in the
same time period so the characters can
actually cross over but they've been
releasing a bunch more previews of that
gold armor of hers that's meant to be an
heirloom that she keeps with her from
themyscira one of her more famous
ancestors just built it out of the
pieces of a bunch of other amazon's
armor they claimed that when they were
filming it was the gold armor that was
the big secret they tried to keep that
secret while they were doing the movie
which i think is kind of weird because
you think that comic book cheetah form
is what they would try to keep secret
kristen wiig even said that they
wouldn't let her take any pictures of
her cheetah costume when she was in full
cheetah makeup but as you can see a lot
of this is special effects like she
probably walked around in motion capture
with a bunch of dots on her face and
then they put this on her later but
everyone let me know in the comments
what's your favorite part of this and
what are you most hyped up about for
wonder woman 1984. obviously there's a
bunch more trailers coming today i think
some of them even leaked early but
they've been taking them down so there's
gonna be a justice league snyder cut
trailer next there's a black atom panel
the rock has been teasing a bunch of new
footage for that james gunn has a
suicide squad panel and he said he's
going to show off a first look then matt
reeves has a big batman panel happening
tonight there's going to be a bunch of
stuff happening while you wait for
everything click here for my new justice
league snyder cut trailer video and
click here to learn all about ben
affleck coming back as batman in the dc
movies thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]
you